so you're aussie media a media company
that's supposed to be kind of like
buzzfeed you're looking for big
investors to give you money to grow your
company faster the only problem is
almost no one on the internet has ever
heard of aussie or has seen any of your
content organically and yet somehow you
finagled your way into a video
conference with goldman sachs who are
looking to give you 40 million dollars
which would value your obscure media
company at a near half a billion dollars
so what is the best way to seal this
deal when you have no real results to
show for you get your co-founder to
impersonate a youtube executive to
praise how well ozzie is doing on
youtube allegedly don't sue me bro so on
february 2nd 2021 aussie arranged a zoom
meeting with you a goldman sachs asset
management team and alex piper a youtube
executive wink wink
so the meeting starts off but alex was
late a youtube executive was apparently
struggling to log onto zoom
that's kinda odd but whatever i guess
not the goldman sachs executives
and eventually everyone agreed to switch
to an audio only conference call which
is very convenient if you're maybe
looking to impersonate someone's voice
then things only got weirder once they
switch to an old-fashioned voice-only
conference call mr piper from youtube
started telling the goldman sachs team
everything they wanted to hear that
aussie was doing amazing on youtube that
aussie was getting loads of views that
ozzie was making even more money from
ads that carlos watson aussie ceo was a
great leader it was very high praise
especially coming from youtube itself
but there was only one issue something
felt off
as alex piper was talking his voice
sounded a little bit strange almost like
it was digitally altered so the goldman
sachs team said they would get back to
you and then they reached out to alex
piper in private except they didn't use
the email address you provided they
emailed alex piper's assistant directly
at youtube and that's when it all fell
apart a very confused alex piper told
goldman that he had no idea what they
were talking about i was never in a
meeting with goldman sachs or aussie
someone had apparently impersonated a
youtube executive to try to get goldman
sachs to invest in aussie and it didn't
take long for the youtube security team
to figure out who it was it was samir
rao the ceo and co-founder of aussie
media but obviously you had nothing to
do with it the aussie founder carlos
watson said he was shocked and
apologized profusely but the damage had
already been done and it was a little
hard to believe that you had nothing to
do with it especially when the fake
youtube executive was praising the
aussie founder on the phone apparently
the guilty co-founder was suffering from
a quote very personal mental health
issue and quotes
so if you're looking to start a company
to raise millions of dollars to reinvest
back into the business and definitely
not use that money for your own personal
enjoyment what can we learn from aussie
media who went from nothing to steal
nothing while getting over 80 million
dollars deposited straight into their
bank account from investors
goldman sachs north samir rao responded
to our request for comment on that
alleged phone call and neither google
nor the fbi responded to requests for
commentary new york times a report
suggesting that aussie media executives
may have committed securities fraud time
says the company's co-founder pretended
to be someone from youtube and
apparently started to impersonate with
it
with a fake email address as well going
out it was part of my pitch saying hey
guess who my seat investors are that's
an insane lie
[Applause]
[Music]
well first off thousands of youtubers
have built actual media empires without
taking a single cent of venture capital
money so if you want to be like ozzy and
raise something like 80 million to do
the same thing youtubers do while
accomplishing nothing what you can't do
is bucket yourself as just another
youtube channel if venture capitalist
investors mentally bucket you as just
another aspiring youtuber they won't
give you any money we're not gonna
invest in some obscure aspiring youtuber
but bugger yourself as some obscure
aspiring startup and count me in so to
get a better understanding of how you
should frame yourself to extract money
from venture capitalists i thought what
better person to ask than an actual
venture capitalist
there it is jesse
this is jesse randall who spent many
many years working at big venture
capital firms and consulting thousands
of startups who is also now a venture
capitalist himself
if i am a
early stage startup what kind of startup
qualifies for
venture backing like if you're a vc what
kind of startups do you qualify for as
venture backable and what aren't venture
backable yeah so i like to think about
you know a company's potential and
whether or not it's venture backable
really is almost like a dna sequence
right a dna like in an animal it could
be a cat or it could be a lion right we
have to find the dna sequence for a lion
and make sure that it's got all the
components that it can become really
massive you know it doesn't have to be
as big as an airbnb but you wanted to
have the ability to maybe even get that
far because when companies are young you
can't tell so you're analyzing you know
the capabilities of the founders the
size of the problem how acute the
problem is like how much pain people are
actually feeling and then how how the
competitive landscape looks like all
these things that will constrain and
open up opportunities for a company and
that's why it's so important like it's
not every company is venture backable
and that's okay people can build great
businesses that aren't venture backable
uh but the venture backfill ones are
special because they can really
take themselves or at least they have
the opportunity to take themselves to a
much higher level jesse eventually tried
to start his own vc firm but he found
himself locked out not because he wasn't
experienced but because he didn't meet
certain regulations see traditionally
venture capital has only been reserved
for the insanely wealthy seriously it
was nearly impossible for you to invest
in private startups if you weren't
already rich the same goes for starting
a vc fund that is why jesse found a
sweater the vc fund for everyone thanks
to sweater anyone rich or poor is going
to be able to download the app sign up
for free and get to invest in the most
exclusive asset class in the world
venture capital an asset class that
powers the high growth startups of
tomorrow to learn more about sweater's
venture capital revolution pause the
video and join the waitlist for free
with the link below thanks to sweater
for sponsoring this video
see angel investors and vcs aren't
looking for solopreneurs to invest in
they're not looking for any ordinary
company to invest in they're looking for
moonshots companies that have the
potential to explode so big that their
investment of a few thousand dollars can
make them into billionaires that is the
game they're playing so if you want to
extract money from them you have to
appeal to the stream and pitching
yourself as an ordinary youtube channel
isn't going to cut it if i really want
to venture capital butts i'm not a
venture backable company would i be able
to like sell myself enough to like kind
of fool vcs into thinking that i am a
venture backable company
all right now you're getting into dirty
gameplay here so this is this is
probably the biggest thing that venture
capitalists are always looking for is
that the sly
you know crafty uh snake oil salesman
that's in there spinning a crazy story
and telling them all this stuff and it's
you know i think we're constantly
defensive
because we know that there are those
types out there who are trying to
deceive us and so you have to kind of
look past the founder and say is this
founder trustworthy and and that's one
of the things that's most important to
me matter of fact
on my investment criteria number one is
this person trustworthy
and if i feel that a person's
trustworthy then all the other elements
come a lot faster so i have my own way
of kind of digging in to know whether or
not someone's trustworthy but there are
plenty of people out there that do this
and this is why
vcs are kind of hard-nosed sometimes
because they if if they
end up backing someone like that it
could ruin their career right and
because it's their job to figure it out
and so yeah i mean somebody could spin a
good story and basically lie to get
their company to sound like adventure
backable but it's just going to screw
everybody involved and the worst person
that's going to get screwed is probably
the founders because they'll never be
able to raise money again right so
instead you need a legit looking media
website you need to hire actual
journalists you need legit looking
articles and videos maybe you need a
hipster looking office with beanbag
chairs and ping pong tables basically
you need to make it look like they're
getting the opportunity to invest in the
next buzzfeed before it blows up that to
become the next buzzfeed you need
venture capital dollars to reinvest into
the business that is not going to be
profitable for a while but once it blows
up it will potentially make these vc's
billions or at the bare minimum millions
if the media company gets acquired you
see that subtle difference when you
frame yourself as a media brand poised
for hyper growth versus being just a
youtuber this is the kind of thinking
that's gonna allow you to do things like
get goldman sachs to consider throwing
40 million dollars at you and that's
exactly what aussie did it was founded
in 2013 with the goal of creating the
next buzzfeed but for gen z while also
making the media and the news a little
bit more inclusive and relatable and
right off the bat aussie raised 3
million at a valuation of 15.5 million
dollars and if aussie barely has any
viewers and readers today they really
didn't have many in 2013 when they were
just getting started
then aussie raises another 5.4 million
making the company worth nearly 40
million dollars just four months after
they were founded with barely any
readers or viewers then aussie extracts
another 25.2 million dollars from
investors less than a year later making
them a nine-figure company or 134
million dollars to be exact with again
barely any views and these were no
dumbbells that you were extracting money
from these investors included axel
springer the ford foundation google's
chief legal officer at the time and more
add another 12 million in 2017 35
million in 2019 and a 3.75 million
coveted paycheck protection program loan
so i'm not sure how much you looked into
ozzy but how do you think they went
about for like raising all this money
for what seems to be like a glorified
blog post and youtube channel
well
this is this is what i was saying
there's a lot of context that goes into
making those investments venture
capitalists are typically betting on the
future and the biggest win
come from what are often the biggest
bets and those bets are coming from
looking at trends and where you think
the world is going to be
and so i know a little bit about aussie
right and aussie was founded during this
time period when
content was a very hot topic
right and being able to create content
outside of the walled gardens of you
know nbc
and you know tv channels and you know
big publishers like the new york times
and back then facebook was really young
instagram really wasn't that big of a
thing yet you know so the last game was
very different so you kind of have to
step back and give just a little bit of
credit to the pitch and the idea of
where they thought the world was going
to go yeah and the world just ended up
not going that direction and so
ozzy ended up in this position where
they raised a bunch of money and they
were trying to build this thing and it
ended up just not working and aussie
media seemed to be professionals at
extracting money from investors actually
making money and making content you know
the whole point of your business was
pathetic to put it nicely your youtube
videos were getting a few thousand views
on a good day and your website filled
with the latest news wasn't getting much
traffic either and you were starting to
run out of money if you really care
about disrupting big media you're gonna
have to do whatever it takes to get just
one more round of funny just one more
venture check
but i think that the problem comes in
where the founders convinced themselves
that they just needed to raise more
money and that they would underneath the
covers they were doing things that were
unethical that were deceiving investors
and that's where the problem is because
plenty of venture-backed startups fail i
mean 50
of venture back startups totally fail
and nobody gets their money back yeah
step number one claim your website gets
50 million unique monthly viewers but
instead of putting in the work effort
and money to grow your traffic
organically just inflate your stats by
doing things like making browsers with
your website pop-up under other people's
actual browser page and when people find
out just say it's to build your email
list and that it won't actually be
counted as website traffic step number
two do things like claim your ceo's talk
show the carlos watson show is amazon
prime's first ever talk show even though
the show was uploaded to the platform
through what's called prime video direct
an option that lets anyone professional
or amateur upload their content to
amazon for more views it gives the
impression of having something like a
netflix original but it's not step
number three if you head to the aussie
media youtube channel right now you'll
see that it has around 4 000 subscribers
and more than 250 videos some videos
have around 93 views while others have
over 400 000 views but if you look a
little closer those viral videos somehow
only have 10 or so comments and if you
know anything about youtube that's
usually a telltale sign of someone
buying fake views it's not a guarantee
that's what they did but even if you run
a youtube video as an ad you'll
typically get a lot more comments on
that now that you have those
questionable youtube stats you can now
claim that your show has more views than
any other premium talk show that was
launched on youtube but the last straw
was that fake call with goldman sachs
now there's no evidence that proves the
co-founder didn't impersonate alex piper
on his own accord but given aussie's
track record i will let you make up your
own opinion after this incident carlos
watson apologized again but for once
aussie didn't get off without
consequences
after the call with goldman sachs was
exposed goldman surprisingly didn't end
up suing aussie youtube also hasn't
pressed charges against the co-founder
for allegedly impersonating the youtube
executive so for a tiny bit of time it
seemed like they were in the clear
legally
ozzie was hit with a lawsuit claiming
that ozzie was quote engaged in
fraudulent deceptive and illegal conduct
end quote the suit was filed by lifeline
legacy holdings a fund management
company that invested more than two
million dollars into aussie aussie's
journalists ended up quitting and by
friday october 1st carlos watson
announced that aussie will be closing
its doors with most of the 75 staff
members being fired at a moment's notice
after 8 years of burning through vc
money it seemed like the time had
finally come but knowing carlos watson
the end was nowhere near ozzy media is
apparently reopening its doors whether
or not carlos watson has actually
changed or not or if investors will ever
trust them again remains to be seen
so what i never understood was like
people who do list like try to just
raise venture capital to just use the
money what is the benefit to love like
do they just waste the money on business
expenses like lavish parties and stuff
or like how do they
like what is the point of raising the
money you know i think in a lot of
people there's good intentions because
you can't just go and burn the money on
parties because there's oversight
requirements like you won't get away
with it you'll you'll get shut down
before you ever raise more money but
like companies that have ended up
raising hundreds of millions of dollars
or even tens of millions that usually
happens across many rounds of funding it
didn't all come in at once right and so
the stages of progress you have to make
in between those rounds is significant
and so typically a company is bringing
it in and they're burning most of the
money and trying to acquire customers
and they're not coming in or the cost to
acquire the customer is way too high
because the pain point isn't really
there
and so the company isn't burning through
all this cash and doesn't get to revenue
targets that they need to be sustainable
and then you know it's kind of like a
house of cards right you can fake
you can make a little bit of revenue you
can do this stuff when you're younger
and smaller and if you're really good at
spinning a story you can keep moving
through the process and raise more money
but at some point it's all going to come
falling down and there are plenty of
examples of companies where their house
of cards collapse and when it collapses
it collapses really fast
ozzy
and then theranose and then wework and
some of the other really high profile
uh failures took place was because the
founders made the mistake of faking
things in order to try to get to the
next level and get the next
venture-backable check because they they
couldn't accept failure so it's probably
a case of done thinking that the ends
justified the means like i'm gonna
revolutionize big media and disrupt it
but in order to do so i gotta do like my
views or whatever allegedly yeah you
know i gotta get out there right we just
gotta get past this hurdle we just gotta
show this next thing the next version of
the product is gonna be what what you
know makes them breaks the company we've
got to get there all we need is another
10 million dollar check so to get that
check we just got to prove these metrics
so let's let's go buy some traffic and
you know let's do this and do that
because we just got to get over this
next hill and you start you know a
founder can get to this point where they
start justifying the you know
the means you know uh like getting to
that point and doing whatever is
necessary and it's a dangerous mindset
to get into yeah most people who do bad
things they never think that they're bad
they always think that they're doing the
right thing they're on the right side of
history yeah yeah no exactly you know i
think that so much of it too is like i'm
the next steve jobs right like i can
impact the world the way that elon musk
or steve jobs or bill gates did i just
have to hang on long enough to make it
happen and in some cases that's true but
in other cases they're just deceiving
themselves right and there's that that
underlying foundation of what's actually
happening where i think founders can get
in the in this sense of like a false
reality
because they bought their own vision so
much that they can't stand back and
accept the reality that is actually
happening to them
what sucks about situations like these
is that it gives a bad rep for actual
innovative startups that need funding to
improve the world but the thing is even
if you wanted to invest in a great tech
company you can't outdated regulations
won't let you yes it's completely legal
to go bankrupt gambling all your money
away on the lottery it's legal to gamble
all your money away at the casino and
yet if you want to invest your own money
into a private company before it's
listed on the stock market you can't
outdated regulations say you're too
stupid to do so that's why they require
you to be an accredited investor a fancy
term that means you need to be a
millionaire or be making over two
hundred thousand dollars a year to
invest in private startups the system is
basically telling you sorry sucker to
get rich you already have to be rich
sure there are equity crowdfunding
websites that let you invest in private
companies but there's a reason why
you're getting those deals it's because
vc funds passed up on them you're eating
their scraps this really frustrated
jessie so after years of digging through
convoluted regulations he was able to
start sweater the vc fun for everyone
sweater is basically like the advent of
commission free stock trading apps but
for venture capital that means anyone
can download the sweater app from the
app store sign up for free and be able
to invest in the most exclusive asset
class in the world venture capital an
asset class that finances the tech of
tomorrow and you can do this without
already being rich without being
accredited and with the minimum
investment of 500 and no cap it's
accessible to practically everyone the
money you invest gets pulled together
with other sweater members which allows
sweater to put together competitive vc
deals sweater's experience investment
team would then invest that money into
emerging tech and product startups poise
for growth companies you'll see in your
daily life or at work vc investing is a
long-term mindset invest in weight just
like you would for your 401k or ira many
startups take 10 years or more to reach
an acquisition or ipo and with sweater
you can continue to grow your position
through weekly or monthly recurring
contributions and what's cool is that
the sweater front is evergreen meaning
your venture portfolio never stops
growing as sweater continues to invest
you'll get broad private market exposure
to the most innovative venture-backed
companies before they go public to learn
more about sweater's venture capital
revolution pause the video and join the
waitlist for free with the link below
thanks to sweater for sponsoring this
video
what's up guys i'm currently in an
airbnb in london so hence the very old
english aesthetic hope you guys enjoyed
the video today i learned a lot making
it that's gonna wrap it up subscribe for
more free business documentaries just
like this one keep sharpening that mind
stay dangerous out there and i will see
you guys in the next one
[Music]
you